he's been in the forefront of all of the
South Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham
senator welcome it's good to be back in
your hometown making of reprehensible
here's Lindsey how you all know me this
is serious what was the deal Friday okay
so here's the deal
senator plate voted yes in the committee
with the understanding that he would
like the FBI to interview the three Ford
witnesses that were interviewed by the
Republicans on the committee Democrats
wouldn't help us as PJ miss Leland
Leland what's our best friend yeah and
Mark judge
let's see Lisa Murkowski said I'd like
the FBI to kind of check the committee's
homework and we also agreed to interview
miss Ramirez the allegation not printed
by the New Yorker right a week once the
FBI has done their interviews they send
it back to the Senate and if they want
further interviews they'll sit down with
Senator McConnell and see what we can
work out so where to deal for a week we
limited the interviews to three people
named by dr. Ford and miss Ramirez and
we'll see what the FBI finds and it's
now been expanded out by the way the the
president said now this had no it's not
no this is a request by the Senate so
where nobody asked to do miss Ramirez
yeah Ramirez is what Nick no nobody
asked for that not one Democrat asked a
question
the Senators in question did not feel
that was necessary yes a accusation on
his face that makes no sense so let me
go over it again
the doctor Ford witnesses mark judge
Leland and PJ right right and miss
Ramirez that's it do it within a week
report back to the Senate and we'll move
forward NBC News ran this interview not
only was one person that said the other
person said they never heard of her
she literally changed her story
including members she was saying that
there was systematically you know every
almost every weekend those are poor take
care of this in about 30 seconds yeah
what reasonable person would go to a
party witness
drugging of women gang reap raping of
women and go back now more time boys
lined up yeah and go back now more times
and never tell anybody tonight she said
well I didn't say that he put the drugs
in the punch earlier the punch well you
know there why does NBC run this well
NBC here's the biggest offense to me
they've been a co-conspirator in the
destruction of Kavanaugh from my point
of view there was a an anonymous letter
received by Cory Gardner the senator
from Colorado with no return address no
information just a letter accusing Brett
Kavanaugh of assaulting somebody in a
restaurant in 1998 in Colorado right and
Cory hands it to the committee somebody
on the Democratic side leaked that
letter it got on the NBC Nightly News
the fourth allegation do you think they
would have done that if by the way in
Rhode Island that was debunked also
argot do you think NBC would have done
that if this has been a democratic male
nominee what if it was Tom Brokaw all I
can say is that their journalist
integrity has been destroyed over this
case all right
regarding this case it's a very tight
margin in the Senate and you've got Jeff
Flake who knows what your flakes and
well the honest and then who knows what
Lisa Murkowski
and Susan Collins are gonna let me ask
you this yeah you fall one who vote
shortly okay number one I don't think we
will let me tell you why I don't think
we're going to find anything new from
this supplemental FBI investigation to
take Jeff from yes to no I think Senator
Murkowski and Senator Collins want to
make sure that the FBI did their
homework to check the committee's work
that that we you know that our work was
good I think that's what this is all
about no more not expanding it to all
this crazy stuff now what would happen
if something really weird did occur and
we're one vote short here's what I would
tell the president I would appeal the
verdict of the Senate to the ballot box
this good man should not be destroyed if
you legitimize this process by one vote
short will be on to the next person I'd
hate to be the next person nominated I
would feel horrible that we destroyed
Cavanaugh so
what I do I would read Amin ate him and
I would take this case to the American
people and I'd s voters in Indiana in
Missouri and North Dakota and other
places where Trump won saying who he
would nominate if he got to be President
and see if the voters want to appeal the
verdict of their senator so if you say
if you fall one vote short you're saying
I would appeal the case to the American
people for this election in 36 days I
would I would tell the president should
read nominate it's up to the president
but one you would be legitimizing the
destruction of a horrible person I mean
a horrible process and a good person
you'd be legitimizing the worst tactics
I've seen so another one is the Rena
tour American people's referendum this
would be a reference would be an appeal
from a political body to the people who
put us here and see if these Trump
States that elected president Trump to
do exactly what he's doing on cutting
taxes and appointing conservative judges
if they're okay with the decision of
their senator I don't think we're going
to get there I think we're going to get
50-plus but if we felt one vote short
for the good of the nation
I would appeal this to the people of the
country and let them have a say senator
thank you for being with us appreciate
it